en este vídeo vamos a familiarizarnos
con lo que representan diferentes
medidas de ángulos en radiales y bueno
para esto lo que vamos a hacer es
empezar con un rayo que inicia en el
origen y apunta en dirección positiva
del eje de las equis así que bueno
iniciando con esto vamos a empezar con
este rayo rosa y lo que vamos a hacer es
rotar alrededor del origen en dirección
contraria a las manecillas del reloj en
diferentes ángulos y bueno pensaremos o
vamos a averiguar en cuál cuadrante es
el que termina ese rayo así que
iniciando rotamos en sentido contrario a
las manecillas del reloj primero 3 y
sobre 5 radiales después 2 piso sobre 7
radiales y por último 3 radiales así que
bueno lo que lo que hago ahora es
invitarte a que lo intentes tú a que
pongas pausa el vídeo y bueno lo
intentes así que piensa al iniciar con
este rayo en esta posición y rotar en
dirección contraria a las manos
el reloj por cada uno de estos ángulos
bueno en cuál cuadrante vas a terminar
voy a suponer que ya lo intentaste
entonces iniciemos con tres pisos cinco
radiales si rotamos
y bueno si quieres pensarlo en grados a
90 grados entonces bueno nos llevaría a
pi sobre 2
esto es pi sobre 2 o pin medios entonces
bueno esto sería y sobre los radiales en
dirección contraria a las manecillas del
reloj ahora veamos 3 piso sobre 5 es
menor o mayor que pi sobre 2 bueno
veamos 3
y sobre 5
esto es mayor que 3 p sobre 6 ajá
por qué bueno si haces el denominador
menor haces a la fracción mayor así que
bueno 3 piso b 6 eso es lo mismo que pi
sobre 2 entonces voy a borrar esto esto
es lo mismo que vi sobre 2
por lo tanto 3 piso sobre 5 es mayor que
pi sobre 2 así que tenemos que avanzar
más tenemos que pasar de esto pero hasta
dónde vamos a llegar
bueno si llegamos aquí apuntaríamos en
dirección contraria a este rayo ajá
haciendo una rotación de 180 grados en
dirección contraria a las manecillas del
reloj pero esto sería pi esto es para
entonces bueno esto es menos que pi esto
es menos que pi porque pie es igual a 5
sobre 5 radiales entonces tenemos que 3
piso sobre 5 es menos que irradian es
así que estamos ubicados más o menos más
o menos por aquí estaría estaría 3 piso
sobre 5 radiales entonces 3 piso sobre 5
radiales está en el segundo cuadrante
muy bien ahora pensemos en 2 piso sobre
7 radiales 2 piso ofrece 7 radiales pasa
de piso de 2 bueno veamos pi sobre 2
aquí sería 3.5 pi sobre 7 radiales
entonces bueno ni siquiera llegamos a pi
sobre 2 cierto
y ahora dos pies sobre siete es mayor
que cero entonces bueno terminaríamos
más o menos por aquí
terminaríamos más o menos por ahí no
llegaríamos a pi sobre 2 pero si estamos
en el primer cuadrante ahora que hay con
3 radiales una manera de pensar en esto
bueno 3 es un poco menor que pi
3 es menor que pim
y es un poco mayor que pi medios
pep y medios ahora como sabemos esto
bueno pib es aproximadamente 3.14 15 9 y
bueno esto sigue y sigue y sigue por
siempre por lo tanto 3 esta esta esto
está más ubicado a pi que a la mitad de
pi a tres radiales estará entrepiso red
o sip y así iniciamos entonces con este
rayo rosa y rotamos al rayo en dirección
contraria a las manecillas del reloj
tres radiales estaría ubicado más o
menos por aquí
y bueno se vería algo así entonces bueno
estamos rotando este rayo en dirección
contraria a las manecillas del reloj y
aquí estaría tres radiales entonces
bueno está en el segundo cuadrante